I'd love to read some more about less
Alabama you got an article here for us
this one's from Easy Storage and it was
submitted by a patron named
Danielle oh this one's called the top 10
items you should be putting in
storage go ahead Alabama if you are like
most American households you have a lot
of stuff sitting around we own more
items than ever before in history and
it's starting to take over your home
that's why self storage facilities like
Easy Storage have become so popular they
are a quick affordable and convenient
way to store items and clear out the
Clutter from your home we've helped many
people find the perfect space for their
belongings and we'd love to do the same
for you if you're thinking about what
you should do what you should store
start by considering what you want to
keep but not necessarily keep in the
house these might be things of value
both personally and financially and you
want to be sure they're safe and sound
at at all times if you're looking around
for items to stick in your new Self
Storage spot here are some of the most
popular items people bring to our
storage facility all right so let's stop
here we're going to go through the list
one through 10 pretty quickly but let me
just translate this marketing copy to
real world speak for a moment hey TK do
you got a bunch of stuff that well
you're afraid to let go of but you don't
really want to keep it in your house
great pay us some money and will hold on
to it for you we'll get it out of sight
we're promising you it will be out of
mind but I can promise you it won't be
out of mind two reasons one is you're
still going to think about those things
oh I still have to do something with
that stuff but you're also going to look
at your bank account every month and
you're going to see that deduction every
single month and then three years from
now you realize oh I've already spent
$10,000 storing all of the useless
things I don't need in the first place
here's the first the first most common
item in Self Storage holiday decorations
I think that makes sense to hold on to
holiday decorations this is one of those
just for win items it's not a justtin
case item because most people who have
holiday decorations it could be some
lights it could be the fake Christmas
tree that they have in a box that's kind
of beat up a little bit right they've
got the ornaments they've got the
picture frames the candy cane the
stockings yes it makes sense to hold on
to those things hopefully you don't have
a cluttered enough house that you can
have a box of holiday decorations so you
don't have to pay $100 a month to store
your holiday decorations because what
happens you could replace all of those
holiday decorations if you're just
storing them in an Easy Storage storage
locker Easy
Storage easy money into my pockets out
of your
wallet the second item is paperwork this
is another one of those things this is
something that I don't want to deal with
right now and I don't have the space for
it in my home without cluttering my home
I want to get rid of these file cabinets
that are mismatch and they're just
hicking up all this space in my home you
know what I don't want to deal with the
paperwork I don't want to go and scan it
by the way you can do a scanning party
go to theminimalists.com scanning you
can see the scanner that we use and
exactly how you can set up a scanning
party you bring some friends over you
scan some photos and even some documents
if you want and then you're no longer
burdened by the paperwork itself sure
there are a handful of things do you
want a paper copy of I have a very small
file at home that has a few birth
certificate social security card things
like that everything else even my tax
information is all scanned why because I
don't want to be burdened by all of the
excess papers and also if something were
to happen to my house a flood or a fire
where that paperwork could get ruined
well now I have it backed up in the
cloud and on a hard drive so I can't
lose access to the paperwork the same
way I would if there was a fire in my
home yeah you know by the way and and
this is especially true with paperwork
but it probably applies to all these
things on the list you're making me
realize that so much of this is a form
of paying for the right to procrastinate
even longer because whenever you're
decluttering it's like there are some
things that are kind of obvious I know I
need to get rid of that let's just go
ahead and do it and there are some
things like hey I know that I want to
keep that and I'm just prepared to be
honest with myself about it no matter
what anyone else thinks but then there's
all this other stuff that's going to
require some hard decisions we kind of
hide behind the notion that it's up to
something outside of ourselves oh I
don't know maybe I'll need it maybe I
won't and since I don't have perfect
knowledge of the future I'll keep it
around but now it really comes down to
do you choose to use that in the future
or do you choose to end it right now
with that thing both of those require a
lot of responsibility self-honesty and
accountability they're both difficult
choices to make because you got to live
with something hard yeah and that's so
tough and uncomfortable and requires so
much self-honesty that it's just easier
to say ah I won't think about it right
now and so we pay someone else to help
us put off the process of thinking about
it until a later date when we're ready
to confront those fears yeah one way to
handle this is to let go and that's
incredibly freeing even if you let go of
something that you might have needed in
the future it also gives you permission
to let go of thousands of other items
that you don't have to put in storage
you don't have to pay for you're letting
go of one thing that you might quote
unquote regret but you're allowing
yourself to let go of thousands of other
items that you know you are not going to
regret the third item here is old
furniture speaking of regrets I've never
regretted let letting go of an old piece
of furniture when I moved last year up
to ohigh I told the story on the podcast
but I sold all of my furniture and
started from scratch now I was able to
do that because the landlord where I was
renting the condo from here he came in
he said wow who does your interior
design I need to hire them I said oh I
guess it's me and and he's like where'
you get the stuff from and I realized
like this stuff isn't going to work in
our new home as well as it worked here
and so I told him hey I'd be willing to
sell it to you he actually asked me
would would you be willing to sell it
and I said yeah let me think about it so
I put together a dollar amount and he
was really happy with it I was really
happy with it and I walked away from all
of it and there are a few things where
I'm like oh I really liked that chair oh
I really liked that bench but I never
regreted letting it go because it's just
a thing and you know what I would regret
it's been two years now since we moved
and I'd really regret if I put all of
that in storage and then had to pay
several hundred dollar a month to store
all those things for the last couple
years and I also don't have an exit
strategy right now because I've got all
these costs I've already spent $10,000
storing these items five years from now
oh now I start thinking about I need to
hold on to these things I've already
invested all of this money storing them
you made me think about Napoleon Hills
thinking Grow Rich he opens with the
story of a military leader who told his
army when they arrived at a certain
location he says unload the cargo from
the ships and burn the boats either we
succeed or we perish and he opens with
that lesson of burn the bridges that
lead back to comfort I think about when
I first left Applebee's I had such a
good relationship with my manager in
this really heartfelt moment he looks me
in the eye he says Hey things don't work
out and you ever need to come back here
you'll always have a job Applebees and
you gave him a wedgie and said f
you I'm never coming back here I said I
preciate that I'm never coming back to
Applebee's and then I walked out the
door and I was like oh man I hope you
never have to come back bro you better
succeed you better succeed I was so
nervous but I was still proud of what I
had did because I burned the bridge back
to that comfort zone I put some pressure
on myself and says well even if you need
to come back there you just burn that
bridge and that's not an option for you
and I like to see how TK's mind works
when he takes that option away from
himself because if I still had one foot
in the door and I still treated my life
like hey I can always fall back on that
then I'm going to act like it my
ambition is going to reflect that and so
sometimes you got to burn the bridges
that leave backwards sometimes you got
to say hey I choose to say no to this
but what if you need it I choose to get
along without it because I'm going to
bet on myself the version of you that
shows up when you signal to yourself I'm
going to bet on you I believe in you is
so different than the version of you
that shows up when you say I'm going to
always keep one foot in the familiar
just in be just in case I don't have
what it takes to be the person that I
want to be yeah I love the metaphor of
burning the boat getting rid of your
storage locker is burning a boat so you
can't go back to that past you don't
want to go back there anyway you want to
go forward you want to conquer what is
in front of you not conquer your past
yeah the next item old
appliances man if you're holding on to
an old stove or an old fridge for an
indefinite period of time have you even
stopped to ask yourself why you're doing
it I can see a world in which it makes
sense oh you know what we're remodeling
our house and I need to for 3 months
store all of our appliances in a storage
locker oh great tot really make sense
but you know what we just replaced our
fridge I got this old one I don't want
to sell it or donate it so someone else
can get use out of it I want to hoard it
and I want to pay to hoard it every
single month that seems like a bad idea
the next one TK the fifth item books now
you really enjoy books you got a lot of
books at home do you ever feel compelled
though to now go get a several hundred a
month storage locker to put your books
in no man like I have them so they can
be with me they're never going to a
storage locker if I'm in a position to
put them in a storage locker then I'm
just going to give them away to somebody
who I believe will read them and I think
that can be said for any of our things
like why do I want my things to be away
from me do I hate my things that much
that I need to cast them away onto this
storage Island the next item is valuable
collections or
antiques okay I can understand this if
you have some things that are valuable
to you but how valuable is it and what
are you storing them for why don't you
want to display those antiques why don't
you want to display those collections as
opposed to sticking them on the
outskirts of an exurban town that is you
know 30 miles away just so what you know
that they're there and what are you
going to do once a quarter you go out
and you look at those baseball cards and
you thumb through them in the middle of
the desert heat or in the middle of the
Midwest cold and you say all right I
looked at my baseball card collection
now I can go back home same thing with
the Antiques I get it if you're like I
want to sell these things and I want
them out of my home right now great
store them until you want to sell them
but holding on to those things in
perpetuity seems like the least ideal
way to have a collection that you
appreciate yeah valuable in what sense
economic value like I can sell it make a
lot of money well then why am I paying
money to leave it some somewhere where
it's unsold why not put it out on the
market or use value okay well why don't
not actually use it what kind of value
does it have and asking these questions
doesn't mean you are required to answer
it in a certain way or to answer it in
the way we think you ought to answer it
but to treat ourselves and our desires
as if they shouldn't be questioned as to
treat ourselves as if we can't possibly
evolve who we are today might be very
different than who we were when we
inherited those things or when we bought
those things and asking questions is a
way of resp respecting ourselves that as
an entity who I am is always changing
always growing up and it's important for
me to always check in with my desires to
make sure I'm upgrading my dreams
upgrading my desires to reflect the
person that I'm in the process of
becoming yeah next item this one is I
think the most
pernicious physical media Alabama can
you just read this one I was going to
ask you if I could I'd be glad to Media
formats seem to change quickly we went
from records to tapes to CDs to digital
files in what felt like the blink of an
eye just because you've moved on to the
next format doesn't mean you have to
part with the old ones we'll keep that
eight track collection safe for you so
you can get it out when you need a dose
of nostalgia which you will never do
that's the on honest appendix to this
paragraph which you never going to do
which by the way could be the appendix
to this entire article you can do all
these things with our storage but you
won't and why won't you there's a reason
we have a whole segment called obsolete
objects on the podcast where we talk
about something that did serve you the
CDs that I had as a kid were great and
I'm so glad that I had them and the
cassette tapes before that or uh TK was
doing
telegraphs when he was a kid before the
telephone don't age him like that yeah
me and Morgan Freeman we grew up
together he going to
Telegraph no I what's fascinating about
the the the media here is yes you can
have a laser disc and haven't gotten
value from it but doesn't mean it's
going to add any value to your life in
the future and this is an excuse to hold
on to those useless things that are
getting in the way because of what
Nostalgia well Nostalgia is just a
rose-colored rear view but when you
actually turn around and look at it oh
those things that were useful they are
now useless and because they're useless
it's okay to let it go man you know what
a good example of this is a lot of
parents experienced this think about
some of those TV shows and movies that
you watched when you were younger and it
was so good MH you know it was so good
when you remember it you're oh it's
amazing and so you're so excited like oh
we're gonna sit down and we're gonna
listen to the music that I used to
listen to we're going to watch my
favorite movie ever and then you sit
down and you watch it with your kid and
you are so embarrassed you're like how
did I think this was a good movie yeah
how did I like this and you're
apologizing for it and your kids looking
at you like ah now I see why you're such
a loser mom I see why you're such a
loser D you're like what happened and
that's a great example of how we can
victimize ourselves by hanging on to a
memory that doesn't comport with the
reality of who we are today that movie
was good to you but you aren't the
person who thought it was good at that
time you've grown up you've outgrown the
quote unquote goodness of that movie and
in the same way you've outgrown a lot of
the goodness in these things that you
thought were cool when you were 12 15 20
30 whatever it was I did this recently I
was trying to show The Fresh Prince of
Bel Air to my 10-year-old daughter
because I enjoyed the Fresh Prince When
I was about her age that's still good by
the way well that's the problem I have
she wasn't laughing at
all but neither was
I I was like kind of appalled I'm like I
kind of get why Jada treats you this way
now oh don't you you know
what I'm G bring out my Dr you know
what I I got three more things that you
must put in a storage locker immediately
TK clothing toys and baby items here's
my summary here with clothing why would
you hold on to clothing that is either a
out of style or B no longer fit you I
used to be morbidly obese and I had a
bunch of shirts that were double X or in
some cases triple X why would I hold on
to that as a plan to well I guess I'll
gain the weight back and I'll need these
old out ofd Ralph luren shirts from
2003 no letting go of those is also
burning the boat to the self that I
didn't want to be anyway in terms of
toys pass those toys on to some other
kids that will find Value in them I
assure you they're adding value to no
one's life when they're simply stored in
a storage locker they're extracting
value from your life and finally any
baby items I think it's the same thing
there yes you know what what baby items
are really expensive or they're free
because people are always happy to let
go of those baby items because they know
you'll get value from it yeah by letting
go you can add value to someone else's
life but by holding on to it hoarding
these things in a storage locker no one
else is going to get any value but also
it's going to take all the value out of
your bank account I hope you enjoyed
that highlight from the minimalist
private podcast if you like another
highlight check out this video if you'd
like to watch the minimal episode check
out this video or if you'd like to dive
deep into full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast head on over
to patreon the link is in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free